welcome to Intelligence Squared I'm
Gabriel Gatehouse and today I'm sitting
down with Maria racer she's the
co-founder and CEO of the Filipina News
website rappler and recipient together
with the Russian journalist Dimitri
marath of the 2021 Nobel Peace Prize for
her brave commitments to free expression
human dignity and democratic government
in reporting on the authoritarian
duterte Administration
born in the Philippines she was
kidnapped those are her own words at the
age of 10 by her mother and taken to the
United States there she would learn
English excel at high school and go to
Princeton University before eventually
returning to the Philippines she cut her
teeth at CNN during the Heyday of their
dominance of rolling news heading
bureaus from Manila to Jakarta and then
in 2020 2012 along with three other
female Founders she established the
online news site rappler one of the
first multimedia news websites in the
Philippines
while rappler has been recognized
internationally for its reporting the
publication's critical coverage of then
president rajuga duterte and his bloody
and ruthless War on Drugs has meant that
it's journalists and its Founders have
faced danger and uncertainty
the former president and his allies have
launched multiple attacks on rappler
initiating investigations and unleashing
cyber troll armies and earlier this year
Maria lost her appeal against the
conviction for cyber libel there is
still ongoing cases against Maria racer
and against rappler that are being
pursued by the Philippine authorities
and if convicted on all counts she's
been told she faces up to a hundred
years in jail
and yet the Philippine authorities are
perhaps not her most powerful adversary
Maria racer has said of Facebook that it
represents one of the greatest threats
to our democracies around the world she
joins me now to talk about her
incredible commitment to speak truth to
power and why it's so crucial in today's
age of disinformation and declining
democracies which is also the basis for
her new book an excellent book how to
stand up to a dictator
um Maria racer welcome to Intelligence
Squared I'm so glad to be here thank you
very much and for being here with us now
you've talked about social media
destroying a shared reality the place
where democracy happens
could this have happened without your
favorite social media platform Facebook
no I I use Facebook a lot because that's
where we do data and I still use
Facebook but in in the book I I show the
evidence that we had from there right
this is data this is proven but I would
put it to all social media at this point
in time because it's the business model
of social media that commodifies us that
essentially you know they use machine
learning to create these models of us
don't use the word models use the word
clone so machine learning clones us then
they say because we created that clone
this isn't your private thoughts your
Deeds we now own that so that's that
database that these social media
platforms have that is the foundation of
micro targeting that's how they were
able to bring things like Russian
information operations person to person
in hand-to-hand combat right this is a
different time and they know it's better
than we know ourselves uh that's what
the Clone does right it's it's almost
like it's funny I was talking with a
friend about this it's almost like you
went to a psychiatrist and you unloaded
your deepest darkest secrets and then
that psychiatrist then said yo who wants
to buy Maria's Secrets Gabriel's secrets
and it is insidiously manipulative of
you that's what we're living through and
the business model is is what they want
to sell us stuff right
um it's called surveillance capitalism
um the companies themselves these tech
companies make money off advertising and
The Advertiser so this advertising is
very very different from the advertising
we used to do in media where everyone
sees the exact same thing there's lots
of different things but the core problem
the core difference is data right we
news organizations traditional
advertising didn't have that kind of uh
the models the Clones that then chooses
the most vulnerable point to a message
and feeds you that right when you need
it for money so that's the surveillance
capitalism part but then when you look
at it you put it like overlay it with
geopolitical power and we've seen this
different countries and I use Russia
just because Russia invaded you
um Ukraine itself but this is in 2014
was when we began to see these
experiments and this is where you see
the interests of the companies I.E make
more money and the interests of despotic
leaders of power that wants to
manipulate us and you see them align
we've sort of become familiar with this
idea over the past
eight six eight years or so but reading
your book it's very clear that the
Philippines and in a sense your life is
Ground Zero
for this phenomenon of of the kind of
alliance between big Tech and
anti-democratic forces why the
Philippines yeah well up until 2021
Filipinos for six years in a row spent
the most Time online and on social media
I saw that globally I saw that stat in
your book and I was I was amazed what's
the what's the background to that why
are Filipinos so
so online I think you know you before
this we were the SMS the texting capital
of the world right and uh I think Brazil
was a close second with when social
media kicked in but part of it I think
is because our institutions are weak and
the if you want to get something done as
a Filipino you'd better know someone who
knows someone who knows someone right
but there are lots of places in the
world like that right there are but
remember we're also the place where 36
years ago people power happened
um were deceptively familiar because we
were an American colony right so we
speak English
um we're also the place where during the
time of Yahoo digital products were
first tested in the Philippines right
before and you know in in the book I
actually point out the two biggest
stories of my career it's Islamic
terrorism the 9 11 attacks uh and and
this social media this kind of
information Warfare oh these were all
Philippines we're here yeah and and it's
and I I guess it's not even that we're
Ground Zero it was actually that phrase
was used by Facebook by the Cambridge
analytica whistleblower Chris Wiley for
me it's a story I can tell through my
experiences April you and I know micro
macro right uh I can tell you what the
macro trend is and that's the chapter
title of each one but the micro how we
got there you know how it looks Through
The Eyes of someone who is pummeled 90
hate messages per hour I mean the first
time I realized that I was like this is
something really new and how do you what
does that feel like to be at the center
of that kind of a storm
um it's kind of it's kind of like being
in a war zone right right we know when
you're when you enter a war zone you
have to be ready to go in and ready to
go out especially if you're the team
leader and you you're in a Perpetual
state of heightened awareness
in a war zone you can stay there like
two months Max and then come out you
must come out because that is not a
sustainable way to live but how do you
exit the online space I mean and this is
the danger for us right we have been I
mean this has been six years we're
walking into our seventh year where
we're under constant attack and it's the
same methodology globally it's
exponential lies coming bottom up and
then if you have a leader that uses that
if it's information operations they come
top down and that's roughly a year right
so a year of seeding this and then a
year later it comes top down in Tagalog
bibinka where the fire comes from top
and bottom that's uh that's uh one of
the phrases we use but it it's
I think what's happened is it's
normalized certain things that should
never be normal personally is it
sustainable to to remain in between
those two fires
for an extended period of time for you
personally
I mean for me
um part of what's given me certainty is
the data right the work that we do facts
facts and that's the way I simplified it
for the Nobel lecture because so many
countries the US UK when you look at
what is going on this Insidious
manipulation through only political
lenses you will get lost because it is
not about the politics you have to ask
why has politics become a gladiator's
battle to the Dem that isn't democracy
so it's the why that gets you to the
real problem and somehow we need to get
to the core problem which is in the end
we agree on facts that isn't debatable
and that's how we find Common Ground we
used to agree on facts but we don't seem
to anymore anyway I I want to zoom in a
little bit because you you said macro
and Micron I just want to go to the
micro for a second and focus on you uh
how did you find journalism or how did
journalism find you whichever way around
it happened I I fell into it because I
was a very good Asian American when I
went to college my parents wanted me to
be a doctor so I went and did all this
stuff I compressed it into two years
then after I said I didn't want to be a
doctor they said you should be a lawyer
so I also did this right useful skills
well they were very good for journalism
but I think where what I really found
and what I loved was understanding us
you know uh comparative literature
English theater and dance one of the
quotes that I took out of college into
today is a T.S Eliot quote tradition on
the individual Talent where he talks
about the present moment of the past
here he's talking about you know how the
latest novel you read or latest book you
read is affected by the fact that you
read Shakespeare but that your
appreciation of Shakespeare is also
affected by the latest novel you read
and that that to me had such impact
because in the end you realize I began
to realize that that's kind of the way
we live our lives the present moment of
the past and you constantly have to
check which way and you talk a lot about
the past here in this book and the
importance of
of who owns the past who owns history
and who's who's learning from it and
who's forgetting about it yes I Milan
kundera that from the unbearable
lightness of being he says the struggle
of man against Power is the struggle of
memory against forgetting and we this
year elected Ferdinand Marcos Jr
overwhelmingly for president 36 years
after the people power Revolt that
kicked the entire family into Exile
right so we watched our history change
in front of our eyes and that and now
you're watching it repeat itself I hope
not repeat but yes I mean it's back to
the future you know back to my movies
you you mentioned you mentioned the
theater because I'm very interested in
this you took a course in theater before
you before you became a journalist I
wrote a creative thesis I wrote a plan
you put it on in Edinburgh yes yes
what was the significance of that and
and what is the significance of that
still in your work today
so much because there's so many things
that that are unknowable you know like
and and this was when I when I went to
college I studied all all five major
world religions
um religion uh emotions
um these are things that journalists
stay away from we try to focus on things
we can pin down right but in the end
what motivates human beings right I also
studied psychology but what I loved
about the theater is that
um you this is how you find meaning
acting classes strangely enough you know
my acting classes in in Princeton little
exercises something called the mirror
exercise where
um it's actually you know for your
acting teacher will say all right
there's a and b you'll flip on who is
leading and who is following this is a
lesson in leadership for me now and I
use this with with with folks I I help
train
when you switch you switch leaders and
what you get to what you try to get to
is a point where you are moving together
and there is neither leader nor follow I
was going to say presumably it's also a
lesson in empathy in putting yourself in
somebody else's shoes in some in the
mind of somebody else which is very hard
when you're constantly focused on facts
I find but if you think about it right
and I think this is this was my my
difficulty when I first became a
television reporter
um I always it was a tenet for me you
walk in someone else's Elsa's shoes I
guess that's partly religious but you
know walking someone else's shoes and in
acting literally that is what method
acting is and you recreate it and then
you look at the world through those
lenses when I first started reporting I
thought I mean I wrote this you know I
thought that being a broadcast
journalist is the most unnatural way of
being natural and you're acting all the
time acting natural right yeah yeah and
there was like this kind of like I know
everything I I was too young and I know
I didn't know everything and so my boss
at that point then sent back the the
real tape that I had where I did my
stand up for you what do you call them
you call them
you call them yeah and and he said you
know uh put this put a suit on put some
makeup on you look 16 go drink brandy to
lower your voice I was like did you I
did but I think I got drunk before
um I I think that
[Music]
um
being a reporter is such a tremendous
honor like when people let you in and I
think one of the things I loved about it
was you give to get you get the best if
you lower if you lower your Shields if
you give before you ask or something
back and I always thought that was a
tremendous privilege and your career in
journalism has really encompassed I mean
you you cut your teeth at CNN as I said
in the introduction at a point where CNN
was the uncontested boss of the of the
breaking news rolling news you know it
bestroed the world I will say with bbcs
with BBC right yeah no but in terms of
breaking news and rolling news that that
you know CNN invented that basically the
Golden Age and then uh and and then you
you went and you headed ABS-CBN the
largest News Group um in the Philippines
uh still at a time there's a wonderful
story in your book and I think it's from
you correct me but maybe it's it's the
mid-naughties 20 2005 2006. this is
still when
um the for whatever better word
establishment media the mainstream media
still had enormous power to control
world events before social media before
the internet really took hold and
there's this great story that you tell
about a a potential coup
um from the Scout Rangers just just yeah
tell us what happened as an illustration
of the power that the media once had
yeah yeah I mean so first from the CNN
days I joined CNN when it was chicken
noodle news chicken noodle news you know
and they were making fun of us so I
understand what it's like to scale up
which is kind of where Facebook came in
but in this one I felt the power of I
headed the largest news organization in
the Philippines and it was a focus point
of power and there was a coup attempt
that was going on and uh we had a
reporter uh embedded with the Scout
Rangers which was ready to mount the
coup the Scout ranges of the military
so they were remember this is a country
that has had coup attempts led by the
military this was how we had the people
power Revolt in 1986 so whoever controls
the military gets the power and the
formula is always the same military
control then you take over the airwaves
television is the next thing okay don't
have to do that anymore right now it is
a Facebook account now we have a new
playbook right but but at that point
um it was unclear what was happening the
president Gloria Arroyo had already
declared a state of emergency and we
knew that the coup was happening I mean
this is a country where the rumors of
the coup filter out and and our reporter
with this the Philippine Scout Ranger
said you know if you put us on live
right now
um they're they're going to declare the
coup
and then I was like I was in the control
room with our executive producer and I
was like um well well this is a clear
line no so there you are you're sitting
there and you have the power to press
the button the go button on the coup
that was my line right so I told our
reporter
walk out first tell them to walk out
first then we put them on live because I
I mean do you want the responsibility
right that one's what I mean nobody
wants that responsibility we're smarter
at least not journalists right I think
journalists are smart enough to know we
don't know and we don't want to be the
trigger and that to me was one of the
lines in the sand like if we had if we
had made the decision would president
Arroyo this coup would have happened as
it was it didn't they never marched out
and she stayed in power so I don't know
whether we did the right thing but by
standards and ethics and journalism you
did the right thing the right thing yeah
now you you go on you you in 2012 you
launch rappler with
um three female colleagues
and at first you love Facebook you this
Facebook is is the thing that's that
that's driving your new site it's
bringing you success and you think you
think what it's a Force for good
absolutely I was the truest of True
Believers you know and
um because I was hoping that we would
grow rappler I had I did no marketing
budget I took what would have been a
marketing budget and put it towards
Civic engagement so this is after almost
20 years with CNN I wanted to come home
I chose a home and I wanted to build
right I felt the technology social media
I believed in social media for social
good social media for social change our
marketing budget went into creating a
Civic engagement team that went from
school to school the Philippines is a
young country the median age is 23 years
old and I was I was at that point you
know coming home people knew who I was
and we were helping students understand
and how they could use social media for
social good and you know nah it's so
painful you you say you cringe now when
you think about this keynote it's so
painful to be so wrong because this is
now the reason why democracy is dying or
has died in countries around the world
but just talk a little bit I want to
talk about why social media is having
such a corrosive effect but first just
give us a little bit of the context
because you know you launched Rattler
just as the Arab Spring was happening
right right yeah just right yeah yeah we
launched in between so you know the Arab
Spring was a key influence for me but
then uh in 2012 so the elevator pitch
for rappler was that we build
communities of action communities of
action and the food we feed our
communities is journalism I wanted to
you know I was tired of covering
top-down politics because inevitably in
any country I work from the problem is
corruption right power
absolute power corrupts absolutely and
that story of corruption is always there
so I thought how incredible if we can
actually help build institutions bottom
up and that was kind of the model of the
Arab Spring and and uh the the Heyday of
when everyone was was feeling happy
about social media empowerment but then
add this other part participatory media
I was heading the largest news
organizations I had a thousand
journalists under this and imagine if we
which is what we experimented with we
would ask our community Through the
largest broadcaster you know to come and
we built a citizen journalism campaign
we did trainings for our citizen
journalists and then we also asked them
especially during elections to act and
they're easy things you know they're not
nothing is debatable about this you know
go out and register to vote that's easy
when ABS-CBN the largest broadcaster did
this
our commission on elections asked us to
slow down because they couldn't keep up
right there were things that a
broadcaster can do for civic engagement
and the cycle of participatory media we
were able to expose corruption because
Filipinos on the streets would pull out
their phone and send us photos of things
that are wrong
um the largest election related violence
in the world and this is cpj committee
to protect journalists that said this in
2009 uh 58 journalists were killed in
maganda now ampatuan maginder now they
were going to register to vote the
journalists were going with the
candidate and essentially they were shot
and killed and then a back hoe dug their
grave in broad daylight right we got
three messages from a citizen journalist
and that that person I know now is a
member of the military but this was
before any reporter was allowed out of
the main city into this area and his
third message he because there were only
was um was a photo and we didn't run it
but we knew in those three messages
who was killed why people knew about it
and then we had a photo of like three
body spread eagleed with a with a
recognizable car we double checked that
there was a car like that in this Convoy
and that was when we ran it at that
point no journalist was allowed in that
area yet and yet this is to me that was
the the power the high point oh my gosh
if imagine if every institution has a
whistleblower because that's essentially
what citizen journalism is right but so
so this is 2012 and you are thinking
that Facebook and social media is going
to lead to a positive Revolution not
just in reporting but in
citizens participation in their
democracy and more than that technology
to jumpstart development right because
there we were already when I was with
abs starting to experiment with crowd
sourcing right when you get and this is
something we perfected in rappler and we
used it for our climate change efforts
we built technology we kind of asked we
haven't we were the third most disaster
prone country in 2013 because we have an
average of 20 typhoons every year
climate change is very real for us this
is a major campaign for rappler from the
very beginning and we asked we we
literally built a platform that we
handed to government where you can watch
online uh where the typhoon is coming in
and if you need help you just have to
tweet or post or text whatever this was
and and the office of civil defense
actually put this we were all seeing the
same thing and it saved people the goal
here is very real bring down the number
of deaths bring it down from triple from
four digits to three digits to two
digits so you so you go from this place
where social media is your friend is is
helping Revolution
right to four years later in 2016 and
you're going to Facebook saying hey guys
this is all going horribly wrong now
just what happened in those four years
did something change or did you realize
that you'd be naive or was it a bit of
both
I'd say something changed and I would
say that the that they got too greedy
you know because they weren't greedy
before not like this not like today not
like surveillance capitalism today
because remember this is a b testing
right that that got us to this 2014 is a
key just explain what a b testing is is
briefly yes and and simply as you can to
somebody who's not terribly so um so if
you're running a website let's not even
do social media right if you're running
a website and you want to experiment uh
you try one tactic that's your a team
and then your B team is another tactic
right so in this one
um what what the social media platforms
did well so a b testing is just
real-time experimentation and we are
Pavlov's dogs that's the way I would
explain it right
um it's kind of like if you let drug
companies do this and the B Team kills
you know oh five people and then the B
team just at the company then just says
oh so sorry there's no accountability
this is what a b testing actually does
strangely enough okay not that I brought
it there but all right so what had
changed in 2014 if you remember instant
articles came up in the west and then in
2015 in our part of the world right
Facebook rolled out instant articles so
up until then news was really not on
Facebook there was no systemic we were
not coming in
um it was already a driver of traffic
for news websites but it was instant
articles that was kind of the
institutional effort of Facebook to
bring massive to bring news
organizations in but the big difference
I realized was that they never changed
their algorithms of distribution right
so all of a sudden news organizations
what is our Central tenant facts truth
we are accountable for the public sphere
so Facebook brings in all the news
groups we get lots of traffic right
which is
modifying news and when that happens
since they didn't change the algorithms
of distribution and what's the goal of
the algorithms to keep you scrolling
right so you're scrolling but why are
you scrolling because your emotions fear
anger hate
as in 2018 MIT came out with a study
that said lies spread faster than facts
on social media because facts are really
boring we spend our careers learning how
to tell better stories that capture your
attention so once you have instant
articles in and I know this because what
I did is
four news organizations were asked by
Facebook to go on onto instant articles
in 2015. and I said yes okay fine we'll
be one of the four and one of the one of
the guinea pigs and I dumped everything
in
because I wanted a baseline right before
and after I'm very simple that way we
need to have a baseline because this is
like a titration experiment you got to
get it right and I figured if like I
would get time six the traffic through
Facebook then maybe I won't need my
website thank God it didn't happen it
was less than one to one which meant I
was giving up page views on our website
in exchange for nothing basically so
that reminded me that they were
experimenting with news not realizing
the huge impact that could have that was
when it began to change and then as they
brought news organizations in because
they paid Western news organization
significant amounts of money to go on to
Facebook those those algorithms of
distribution didn't change they
continued to to actually
spread Lies Over facts so they they took
a they took a business model that was
essentially advertising which is
persuasion
and grafted it onto a different business
which was
supposed to be about truth telling uh
well yeah so I would know the other way
because I don't call what they do
advertising not the old world
advertising right micro targeting is
very specific it is much more
manipulative than the old world
advertising we need to have so I really
make the distinction of micro targeting
when they grafted news onto onto
Facebook that's when we began to see
shifts happening now you took your
concerns to Facebook in 2016.
immediately yeah yeah what what was that
meeting like how'd it go I mean I so I
had seen this I had already we all had
relationship Managers from Facebook
right and in many ways in the
Philippines we were far ahead they
didn't open their office in the
Philippines until 2016. so I was in
touch we were like Alpha partners for
Facebook because we knew the Philippines
very very well and it's just they didn't
make that much money from the
Philippines right so still profit was
the driver they listened more to people
to countries that gave more money
um so this one I went to Singapore and
in Singapore I had so much data backing
me up I showed them how Free Speech was
being used to stifle Free Speech how 26
fake accounts can influence up to 3
million others you know so if you lie if
you create information operations the
spread was incredible can you can you
give us an example there's a great um
passage in your book about this guy
called Sam who who claims that he that
he essentially made the War on Drugs
this number one issue for duterte's
campaign and and by implication got him
into Power yeah yeah I mean look
um forever I mean we we have these
surveys that have been there forever and
the top concerns of Filipinos never fail
are jobs
um health is there and education maybe
comes down right so it's always do you
have enough money to put food on the
table because we don't most Filipinos
don't this guy comes in young kid
dressed like like he you know dressed
like he's in a punk rock band and he
come comes in and and it makes sense
because what he said aligned with
several things we were noticing that
that he began to create Facebook pages
that were you know about your first date
or your first love or something
innocuous it's almost like a trojan
horse and then once they're there they
began when he began working with the
duterte campaign the goal was to bring
what duterte is good at which was Law
and Order
um drug war the drug war and they moved
the drug war from you from a number
eight concern not to say that it wasn't
a problem so a number eight concern to
number one by the time duterte was
running for office and this guy had he
did he get co-opted by the duterte
campaign or did he
mean to do this from the start what was
his this is I mean the thing here is
this is a learning right like and in the
Philippines was one of the places where
people experimented because you can do
it with impunity uh it the the other
part that's not there is you know the
Philippines is kind of um a fraud
capital for online you know I don't know
if you remember
um the kim.com right yeah his wife is
Filipina he operated in the Philippines
for a period and then there was the the
Q Anon
and the the Watkins Duo are also
operated out of the Philippines yes why
what is it about the film I mean I've
asked this already but is this it it so
it was it was an English-speaking
presumably
um low labor costs is that something to
do very much cost of living is very low
um there's no accountable I mean Law and
Order is weak so you can get away you
can experiment with many things but you
know like the easy part when it was
terrorism
um why did they test the tactics for
terrorism well our airport is like the
United States we had the same systems as
the United States of airport security so
you had
um Mohammed Jamal Khalifa was the
brother-in-law of Osama bin Laden come
to the Philippines as early as 88.
you've robe the defenses well he was
bringing in money for Charities Muslim
Charities so that was the beginning
follow the money we know this right and
then by 1993 after the first World Trade
Center bombing in the basement the truck
bombing Ramsay Yusuf flees to the
Philippines where he begins to train the
Abu sayyaf one of our terrorist
organizations linked to Al-Qaeda later
and then his uncle is the architect of 9
11 Khalid Sheikh Muhammad they were
living in the Philippines so one of the
some of the stories I did for CNN was
talking to their girlfriends and how
they experimented I don't know if you
remember the 2 2002 shoe bomber Richard
Reed coming out of London Airport right
well that plot the liquid bomb plot was
tested in the Philippines in 1994. and
it was actually Ramsay Youssef who went
through airport security got it in his
shoes where there's a two inch think Gap
think thick Gap and they got it onto a
Philippine Airlines plane it exploded
under the seat of a Japanese businessman
and killed that businessman you know so
these are things so why you asked why
the Philippines because I think
we're we're deceptively familiar to
westerners and we use similar systems
we're connected to the rest of the world
we were even our language is very
familiar those are some of the ones but
look even things like uh Donald Trump's
likes
a certain number kind of a lot one in 27
come from the Philippines right and most
recently we were looking at who are the
foot soldiers of these information
operations that are now kind of being
outsourced to the rest of the world so
but you you took these concerns just to
go back to that Facebook meeting in
2016. this is the book is Facebook got
absolutely hammered over you know
Russian disinformation on the site in
the 2016 election and people sort of
accusing them of uh of of of of giving
the election to Trump essentially by by
playing host to all of this
disinformation but that was in November
you brought your concerns to them when
really early it was like
um I think the most read the latest one
the meeting itself happened in August of
2016 and uh and we were I remember this
because I as a joke I was saying you
know guys this is so alarming that if we
don't do something about it Trump could
win this has Global implications and we
all laughed there were five of us around
the table we laughed and then of course
when Trump won you know after the
November elections they asked me for
more of the data again
so they weren't taking you seriously
I think they were getting this
particular group did not I think they
looked at it with her this is after all
the policy and news Partnerships and and
they were their task was in some ways to
mollify me to pacify me right make you
go away yeah but but you know we could
see it we could see it and I kept
bugging them I in fact I held the story
this is how important it was I was
working on this story my co-founder and
I did the data yeah I held on to it
because I was naive enough to think that
if they know the problem they can then
solve it so that I could then get you
know so this is what Facebook did to
prevent this from happening I waited I
waited a month right and then we finally
came out with it
um without any statement from Facebook
without any I was hoping they would give
me data right yeah and you could you put
a warning up on your website and they
took it down well that also happened
yeah yeah you know
what did you conclude from that right
what does it show you
um let me just say I am an optimist and
I was hoping and continued and I still
continue to work with Facebook today but
I've learned since after the Cambridge
analytica Scandal when we became a
fact-checking partner there are only two
Filipino fact-checking partners of
Facebook and we accepted it at that
point I knew that Facebook knew they
were they I I was part of many meetings
where they were trying to figure out and
there were smart people there who knew
what to do much later we find out that
they weren't listened to you know the
release of the Francis Haugen the
documents the internal documents you
write in the book I believe that
Facebook represents one of the greatest
threats to our democracies around the
world and I am amazed that we have
allowed our freedoms to be taken away by
technology companies Greed for growth
and revenues I mean is that is that
basically it they didn't do anything
about it because they were making money
off it yes and that is both the
anecdotal and reporting that came out
afterwards every single thing we had
said was verified later and then you
know we come out with it deny deflect
and I'm like thinking well oh well and
we weren't the only ones telling them
this right Ukraine have had done that
President Obama said he did but it was
it was a certain it's it's an arrogance
and a and an ignorance about the the
what happens when Big Data
changes human behavior right when the
change of scale literally changes and
when
growth quote-unquote economic growth
profit becomes the ultimate goal goal
the ultimate good there's like
everything else will flow from that
and so therefore that is your ultimate
aim right isn't that horrific I mean you
know that's when I begin to think
because American CEOs will always defend
a businessman tell me this all the time
they'll say yes but that shareholder
value uh guess what there's more the
world is a shell well more than that
right there's you the president
um or the CEO there's a line between
amoral immoral and evil and in the book
I do compare this to the tobacco
industry now you say because I just want
to dig a little bit into this whole idea
of disinformation and lies because yes
social media has kind of supercharged it
but it's not it's not like this stuff
didn't exist before the internet right
so so you say that lies repeated over
and over become fact in the online
ecosystem and that's a great way of
putting it and then we've I've seen that
myself in my own work working with
people who believe in Q Anon this kind
of crazy conspiracy theory about a cabal
of satanic Peter Pan miles who stole the
2020 election
etc etc
but
unique to social media this this has
existed before and and lies or uh
untruths have been told in the
traditional media ecosystem as well and
many of Donald Trump's supporters would
point for example to the whole kind of
Crystal dossier and the Russia gate
um story that actually most of it turned
out not to be true which was well it was
supercharged online but it was also just
supercharged in the papers right and on
CNN and MSNBC yep there's a big
difference the difference it's scale
it's scale which is what these tech
companies aim for scale
3.2 billion connected in a way we never
have been before propaganda
exponentially said a million times right
targeting specifically the weakest and
I've seen this I've had family and
friends become part of the Russian
disinformation system when when Facebook
took down the IRA and the gru so did
some accounts of people I knew right
because this think of it like a virus of
lies that infects it's a closed system
but when you in fact infect it it
spreads so that spread so here's the big
difference with propaganda in the old
days or even intelligence work in the
old days when it moves at human Pace you
can react at human speed when it moves
at the speed of exponential data right
there's a big difference between an
Excel sheet and big data that is the
world we live in that is when we become
Pavlov's dogs and this is a behavior
modification system it it literally it
impacts us at three levels people you
know the first is psychologically you're
pounded I mean certainly the impact on
me if I didn't have the data I would
have been silenced and that is a big
chunk of society that are silenced women
in particular the second layerism is a
layer I studied when I was looking at
how radicalization how the virulent
ideology of al-Qaeda spread this is
sociologically in groups right and we
can go back to like the 60s where the
Milgram studies the the
um the kind of Conformity studies that
show that we behave differently in
groups I mean in high school peer
pressure excerpts you know shifts your
behavior and then the very last one is
the part that we don't discuss at all it
is emergent human behavior at scale
species level we are being changed by
the technology to our worst selves you
know and that to me is what is so
alarming because this these are all
we're only talking about the cascading
failures the death of democracy is only
a cascading failure but it is literally
changing us as a species and that's part
of the reason I do think we need
legislation this is harmful
there's something
that makes me slightly uncomfortable
about some of these conversations which
is that there's a sort of base level
assumption that Trump is a bad thing
that brexit is a bad thing
um that uh I mean duterte will be a bad
thing right and I'm not saying I'm I'm
not saying I do or don't agree with that
but but we do know for example that you
know nearly 75 million Americans for
example voted for Donald Trump uh in
2020 even though yeah though he he lost
so I I'm I'm trying to I'm trying to
figure out whether before we get to
social media is being weaponized by bad
people to do bad things which I think
we've absolutely established was there
something else rotten in the state of
Denmark in in the state of kind of world
democracies that
that meant that this was so easy to do
so let me first say that it isn't that
it isn't these political things right uh
I'm actually not taking a position what
I am after is individual will agency
right because it is the Insidious
manipulation that's wrong doesn't matter
if we all voted for brexit because we
chose to do it right it's agency that is
critical for me in this instance we have
evidence of information
operations in Trump's elections
Americans and this is something that
came out in the Senate intelligence
committee reports the data was released
there is a Mueller report that's a
thousand pages long that show that the
Gru and the Ria targeted Americans
targeted identity these flash points of
emotions right but things that that do
already exist right they exist but it's
different when it's weaponized right so
what I mean by that is like something
ident like in identity like black lives
matter which was a positive right but
what did IRA and Gru do they targeted
both sides it's like inciting hate I
know how easy it is to make someone
angry and make them pull out a gun right
in the real world now imagine if that is
always what is happening so it it pushes
us towards a level of violence and we've
seen this online violence is real world
violence but so let me go back to your
question about you're saying are we not
like that because this is also something
the tech the technologists say we are
only mirroring what humanity is that's
not true uh you know the telephone lines
only delivers the message the telephone
companies don't decide which messages
you get to hear ring right the companies
the tech companies decide and what they
have done is prioritize lies hate anger
fear and this shifts our our development
as human beings as societies as
governments it is I I feel great empathy
for anyone in government today because
what do you do if you're trying to reach
people if you're really trying to do a
good job but no one believes you this is
where we are because you you talk a lot
in the book about
um shared reality and this is something
that I've been sort of grappling with in
the last few years as I've spent a lot
of time in this kind of right-wing Trump
Mega world where where it feels like
you're actually in a different reality I
sometimes compare it to to this or in
fact it wasn't my idea it was one of
Trump's sort of operations with this guy
called um Jack passobic who who talked
about
um the fact that the 2016 election was
like the electorate were watching two
different movies all with the same
characters but with entirely different
plot lines and I'm constantly searching
for and you can see how people are
weaponizing that and you can see how
people are using the
um the technology to do that but I'm
constantly trying to see it from the
other side's point of view and I'm
wondering whether
you know in the run-up to
uh let's say the 2016 election if a if
somebody who genuinely was a trump
supporter would look at
The Establishment media the world that I
come from and you come from and go
these guys are making up a completely
parallel reality about how Trump is this
kind of uniquely evil and corrosive
presence right or the same with brexit
there were you know millions of britons
who looked at the reporting ahead of
brexit and thought that is not the the
Britain that you are describing is not
the Britain that I recognize so I wonder
if I don't want to be like both
sidesisms or what about isms but you
know are we all guilty of of creating
our own realities and not seeing other
people's realities I mean we always have
been but the difference is that you
never had establishment
do this right so what do I mean by that
I mean that in the past when news
organizations were held accountable for
the public sphere regardless of what you
can think right whether you're left or
right or whatever and I mean let's not
even talk politics everyone has
individual beliefs that's called our
individuality but we all agreed to be in
a shared space and news organizations
were accountable for that right a
government official who lies is very
clear he lies it used to be that we
would do a story and expose a lie and
then the official will say yes thank you
I am so sorry I will never do it again
when was the last time you had that that
was a very long time right now it's
double down on the LIE and because of
and again what I think you are
describing is the cascading failure
enabled by this by this do you think it
has been do you think there's been a do
you think there's been a tendency
sometimes in the established media to
not hold the establishment to account
because they feared that it would
fuel this corrosive other side of
politics
I I you know look I know that this is a
very tenuous time for traditional media
not only because of the changes in our
information ecosystem of what online has
done right but also because
power has shifted and you like I talked
to a lot of news heads all around the
world where they say how do we restore
trust and I keep going back to we cannot
restore trust the power we used to have
is like the vestigial tape we no longer
have it and it is a digital tale I love
that right it is in the tech company's
hands and as long as they use this
system we will never have a shared
reality because the entire incentive
structure is upside down it's like you
telling your kids go lie all the time
because you're going to get what you
want anyway lie all the time that it's
not the world we live in there are costs
to these types of things are there still
positives to social media and I'm
thinking for example of Russia a place
where
state-controlled television
uh is the is the big beast in the room
and we're actually in on the in the
online spaces people can still find real
information about this war that's going
on in Ukraine yeah no I mean there are
deaf and this is part of the reason even
though my language is strong it's
fact-based and evidence based I want
regulations in place to protect us but
it's more than what's happening in
Ukraine right it is I mean me too you
know you have Iran and the women who are
using this Twitter for all of the things
that that Elon Musk has done in the last
few weeks was a global public sphere
where activists used it for good right
there is still a lot of good but I'm
just saying we have more than reached a
few years ago we reached the point where
the good was outpaced by the bad and
where democracy begins to die I mean I
it is not a coincidence that sixty
percent of the world now lives under
autocratic rule and that the number of
democracies has rolled back to 1989
levels this is hand in hand the rise of
an apple bomb calls it autocracy Inc I'm
going to call it kleptocracy Inc right
this is in the real world and then that
goes hand in hand with this kind of the
nervous system that is pushing the rise
of and I guess I'm going to say the far
right but I don't take a political
position here right let's strip off the
political lenses I am after a shared
reality because facts are not debatable
this is a glass of water right if you
don't believe me drink it right I can
prove it uh and and and then give us
agency to make a choice and democracy
requires that individual will and
requires we listen
do you think democracy Will Survive
we're in the last two minutes it is you
know 2024 will be critical because we
look at the number of Elections this
year next year where you have turkey
Nigeria African nations India begins its
uh Regional elections and then 2024 is a
red letter year
um the big ones Indonesia the world's
largest Muslim population India the
world's largest democracy and the United
States I mean you have the EU also in
2024 so if we elect more illiberal
leaders democratically and they collapse
institutions in their own countries and
then Ally together to shift geopolitical
Power Balance you know there's something
called the Shanghai cooperation
organization that's led by China and
Russia they last in September they
brought in Turkey Myanmar and turkey
Myanmar and Iran Iran right so
geopolitical power is Shifting and it
starts at the kind of molecular level
the person-to-person level and it has
been enabled by Tech and here's the last
part I would say right
um the Chinese understand this because
they have two versions of tick tock
you know this right they have two
versions they have two versions I didn't
know that there is the Chinese version
the one inside oh okay yeah yeah so I'm
the one that you can get and the one
that you that they export yeah um and
this is Tristan Harris who was actually
who had said this he said that uh in
China you know if you're 14 years old
and Below Tick-Tock will will cut off at
a certain point you can't have a certain
they keep the kids because they know
it's harmful they give them educational
videos and at a certain number of hours
they stop you can't watch more than it
sounds like a great idea that's he
called it the Spanish version sorry the
spinach version of tick tock right right
Eat Your Greens Eat Your Greens but then
the one they exported to the rest of us
in the world is the opioid
revenge for what we did 150 years ago I
mean but again like and I don't think
it's a coincidence as a tech CEOs you
know the people who built this to keep
their kids off of this yeah
Maria racer that sounds seems like a
suitably well depressing uh what place
to end it you're an optimist though
which I can see you sitting here
opposite me smiling and full of energy
and
what we do ready to do stuff well what
we do today matters right the data is
there we know what it's doing to us you
know I say think slow not fast
collaborate together to protect the
facts I mean I don't want to see
democracy die Gabriel right there's so
many journalists who are doing so much
and and citizens I think it's not a
coincidence that the Nobel the Norwegian
Nobel committee last year gave the Peace
Prize to journalists and this year they
gave it to Civil Society to activists
this is the time to act so act now Maria
racer Nobel Peace Prize winner and
author of how to stand up to a dictator
which is available now here it is it's a
great book
um and you are a great person so thank
you very much for being with us
um I'm Gabriel Gatehouse and you've been
listening to or in some cases watching
intelligence Square thanks for joining
us